what do you think is going to surprise
people when they finally see what you're
working on
it
you know doing something that takes
place in the high Republic that hasn't
been seen in live action before and
seeing how that relates to what already
exists I think will be the most exciting
for the fans
got it very guarded
sorry what do you actually I like
learning about the behind the scenes the
making of shows so what surprise what
has surprised you about like the behind
the scenes of the making of the series
honestly the amount of the like the
practicals like the sets are fully built
so when I am in the Jedi Temple I am in
a Jedi Temple you know we're not on the
volume so we're not imagining what's in
front of us or behind us there's not a
lot of blue screen
um the aliens are puppets and we are
speaking with the puppets
um so yeah one of the things about the
Jedi Temple is that there could be some
cool books and things that I'm just
curious maybe how some books and stuff
play into because fans love that stuff
how that play into maybe the plot
the books like what's been written yeah
like with characters reading about
things from the past you know right yes
I that I'm I probably can't talk about
that
of course it's hard the brain is like
uh any chance I'm gonna get your
character name no
but I can tell you that I play a Mary
Allen an elder Jedi Master who is
extremely powerful
so what is it like uh being in scenes
where there's a bunch of lightsabers
being used
the lightsaber is uh very cool you saw
the teaser right yeah the footage is
incredible yeah so like that shot where
everyone takes out the lightsaber I just
thought was so amazing it just was all
the different colors of the lightsaber
so powerful yeah no 100 yeah um I'm
gonna leave it there and I'm just gonna
say good luck with your speed dating and
I can't wait to see the show thank you
thank you